du temps et pour cela je vais vous
demander de continuer à faire des
sacrifices et plutôt d'en faire
davantage mais pour notre intérêt
collectif dès lundi et jusqu'à nouvel
ordre les crèches les écoles les
collèges les lycées et les universités
seront fermés pour une raison simple nos
enfants et nos plus jeunes selon les
scientifiques toujours sont celles et
ceux qui propagent semble-t-il le plus
rapidement le virus
même si pour les enfants ils n'ont
parfois pas de symptômes et heureusement
ne semble pas aujourd'hui souffrir de
formes aiguës de la maladie
c'est à la fois pour les protéger et
pour réduire la dissémination du virus à
travers notre territoire
le service de garde sera mise en place
région